tomaten gehören ja schon eher zu den
empfindlicheren kandidaten im
gemüsegarten die können super schnell
krank werden und um das zu verhindern es
ist ganz wichtig dass du ein paar von
den fehlern die ich immer wieder sehe
bei ganz vielen hobbygärtnern dass du
dir in deinem garten vermeidet und
welche fehler das sind das zeige ich dir
in diesem video und der erste fehler ist
dass viele leute ihre tomaten einfach zu
dicht nebeneinander pflanzen tomaten
haben eine gefürchtete krankheit das ist
die braunfäule und sie kann sich vor
allem dann ausbreiten wenn die tomaten
sehr dicht stehen und die blätter feucht
werden vom regen oder vom schwitzwasser
im gewächshaus und sie dann nicht
abtrocknen können das heißt um gesunde
tomatenpflanzen zu haben es ist total
wichtig dass die schöne abtrocknen
können dass der luft durch streichen
kann und dass sie nicht zu dicht stehen
deswegen beim pflanzen immer auf den
weiten pflanzabstand achten von ungefähr
40 bis 45 cm und am besten nicht mehr
stichwort braunfäule es gibt ein paar
sollten die sind super freiland geeignet
da kann ich dir gerne mal ein paar hier
einblenden
aber nicht alle sorten sind für das
freiland geeignet und deswegen schaue
auf jeden fall bevor du deine pflanzen
nach draußen setzt ob die sorte denn
überhaupt mit wind und regen vor allem
regen klar kommt oder ob das vielleicht
ein kandidat ist der in einem
gewächshaus oder zumindest unter einem
tomaten dach vielleicht besser
aufgehoben wäre
es ist immer besser wenn man den tomaten
ein geschütztes plätzchen anbietet und
die eben nicht nass werden wenn es
draußen regnet weil sie davon super
schnell krank werden können also wenn du
tomaten zum beispiel auf dem balkon
anbaut dann rückt eine töpfe immer schön
dicht an die hauswand so dass sie
vielleicht nur ein bisschen unter dem
dachvorsprung stehen oder zumindest von
der wand ein bisschen geschützt sind ja
wahrscheinlich größte fehler den ich so
seeber hobbygärtnern ist dass viele
leute sehr sehr ungeduldig sind und viel
zu früh mit der anzucht anfangen
ich habe um dieses videos für euch film
zu können im dezember meine tomaten
aussehen müssen das war so um
weihnachten herum damit die dann für das
video rechtzeitig groß genug sind und
diese tomaten die leiden jetzt wirklich
die sind viel zu groß gewesen als ich
sie dann nach draußen pflanzen konnte
das kann ich euch auch gleich mal zeigen
wie die im vergleich zu denen aussehen
die ich normal vorbezug
habe zum richtigen termin hier seht
immer eine tomate die ich im dezember
vorgezogen habe seht ihr was das für ein
schwächliches ding geworden ist weil die
einfach viel zu lange im haus ausharren
musste
und das hier ist eine die mitte märz
vorgezogen ist dies viel kräftiger und
gesünder das ist ein riesen unterschied
im vergleich dazu sind hier mal tomaten
die ich mitte april erst im haus
vorgezogen habe das ist für meinen
geschmack schon viel zu spät gewesen
weil jetzt das ist anfang juni und die
sind immer noch total winzig also es ist
schon sehr wichtig dass man bei der
tomaten anzug weder zu früh anfängt noch
zu spät und einfach an den richtigen
zeitpunkt denkt das heißt meiner
erfahrung nach ist mitte märz der
optimale zeitpunkt um tomaten
vorzuziehen die ins freiland kommen und
ende februar anfang märz wäre der
perfekte zeitpunkt um die gewächse aus
tomaten vorzuziehen aber nicht im januar
anfangen und erst recht nicht im
dezember und ein regiefehler haben wir
auch noch im gepäck was sagst du florian
was ist der größte fehler im
tomatenanbau ein fehler den ich am
anfang auch viel gemacht habe eine
tomate wächst und wird groß und man will
sie immer so schön verwöhnen mit viel
wasser und mit viel dünger viel hilft
viel
mein tipp nein lass die tomate müssen
hungern
lasst sie durften nicht zu viel gießen
und vor allem noch viel wichtiger nicht
zu viel düngen
ich mache am anfang so eine kleine
handvoll hornspäne und auch eine kleine
handvoll organischen dünger vielleicht
ein kleines bisschen kompost das war's
dann kriegt die nichts mehr wo die
tomaten entwickeln sich super und der
geschmack ist viel intensiver als wenn
ich nur als wenn ich da ganz viel
hinschmeißen und vor allem im dauertief
wie das ganze wasser in die früchte und
ist nehmt einfach den ich mal grob
dankeschön für deinen beitrag checkt auf
jeden fall florians kanal
selbstversorger rigotti aus der ist
unten in der video beschreibung verlinkt
fehler nummer sechs ist was für die
ganzen balkon gärtner unter euch und
zwar sehe ich viel zu oft dass leute
tomaten in kübeln pflanzen die
eigentlich zu klein sind man muss sich
das mal vorstellen viele gemüse die
haben ein genauso großes wurzelwerk
wieder oberirdische teil der pflanze und
das ist bei den balkon um die sind auch
nicht anders deswegen ist jetzt kein
zweifel ob für ihre tomaten anschaffen
aber 20 liter sollte der kübel unbedingt
fassen damit die tomaten darin gut
wachsen können das ist ganz wichtig
damit man am ende dann auch spaß an
seinem balkon tomaten hat und das gilt
übrigens auch für ganz viele andere
balkon gemüse sorgt dafür dass die genug
platz haben in ihren töpfen damit die
auf ihrem balkon auch richtig glücklich
um groß werden können wenn ihr tomaten
im gewächshaus angebaut dann habt ihr
ein großes problem da kommt kein wind
rein das heißt die tomaten werden nicht
bewegt so dass die blüten nicht bestäubt
werden und da kommen auch keine
bestäuberinsekten rein
deswegen muss man im gewächshaus
unbedingt nachhelfen um die tomaten zu
bestäuben damit man eine gute ernte hat
und wie das funktioniert das zeige ich
euch da trieben in dem video also schaut
da auf jeden fall mal vorbei ansonsten
geht raus macht die welt ein bisschen
grüner und wir sehen uns am samstag
wieder für ein neues video